all right but we're going to begin this
hour with the story of a ukrainian chef
and his fight to follow his dream chef
morali dilbazi was forced to close the
doors of his newly opened restaurant in
kiev when the russians invaded his
country imagine putting that sign in the
window but recently he was able to feel
inspired once again thousands of miles
away at a restaurant here in brooklyn
elaine keanu caught up with the chef and
learned about his journey back to
creativity
in the kitchen
at this farmers market in new york city
chef mirali del bazi marveled at
america's bounty the types of produce
he's seeing here for the first time will
serve as inspiration for his passion
cooking i'm not good artist
but i'm not a bad cook so
dilbazi is from ukraine and while he may
not consider himself an artist his
creativity in the kitchen allowed him to
fulfill a lifelong dream last year
in late 2021 despite a host of
pandemic-induced challenges he opened
madali his fine dining restaurant in the
capital city of kiev
four months later russia invaded ukraine
what did you think when you first
learned about the russian invasion life
changed because it was your dream about
restaurants consulting one second you
felt like your dream was over yes i felt
like this he and his general manager
olena lucetska made the agonizing
decision to leave ukraine and travel to
germany i never faced the situation when
in your life the war happened and what
was like what should we do to to move on
to continue
the war forced the restaurant to close
temporarily its pantry then served a
different purpose one cdp chef started
to cook for ukrainian military use all
our products which we have in the fridge
del bazi and lucetska now find
themselves across the world thanks to a
food critic and fan who introduced them
to this brooklyn restaurant through
september they'll oversee the menu and
staff at fulgerhans laundromat where the
green facade is just as vibrant as the
ideas of its residents
though the sign may suggest otherwise
this is a place where rising chefs are
invited to take over for a period of
time
implementing their own unique visions
much in the same way owner hugo ivernat
reimagined the storefront itself
what is your mission with this
restaurant the whole idea for them is to
have a space where they can like create
their own menu find their own identity
so for us it's like learning a lot of
different food without changing
restaurants what is your hope in
bringing a ukrainian chef here to
brooklyn if mirali is able to do what he
loves to do
even if it's not in ukraine but
somewhere else and we can help him
achieve that i think this is the first
step
delbazi's restaurant back home is open
once again operating with a limited
bistro menu but he's been able to
recreate his fine dining operation here
with a menu of dishes they served in
kiev
crafted with traditional techniques
contemporary twists and an emphasis on
seasonality
one of tonight's offerings a tomato what
is this dish called he called it like
herlon or tomato
that is fabulous there's many many
flavors that i taste what else is in
there you said honey it's only juice of
tomato you made the honey from the
tomato juice yes
i have never had
tomato honey it's a showcase of the
creativity that delbazi believes is so
important see you smiling why are you
smiling tell me why marali because i see
the joy yes in ukraine there's
war but
we can also can go be creative in dark
time and here i can use energy for
creating something not for thinking
about the war
for cbs morning's elaine quijano
brooklyn new york
i love new york because they allow
people to continue to chase their dreams
yes even when they're running from
something like that what's going on
another good restaurant in brooklyn gail
for you to come time for you to come
over the bridge once again another
example of why all the cool things and
cool people tony the couple live in
brooklyn that's right